Let's look at the solution to our
not most recently used replacement
policy quiz.
We have these axises, and
now let's see which ones might be
hits and which ones might be misses.
This one is definitely a miss because
we have nothing in the cache.
And now we have brought
A into the cache.
This one is definitely a hit.
No we're going to access B,
and this is definitely a miss.
And we're going to put B in a separate
place in the cache from where
we put A because A is
the most recently used block.
So we will put B in one of
the other three blocks.
And we definitely will put B in
a line that doesn't contain A.
So we will not take out A because
A's the most recently used block.
We will choose one of the other
three lines to evict to put B there.
So far, if this is our cache,
we have A and B there.
Now we will access A and have a hit,
so C is definitely a miss, and
at that point A is the most
recently used block.
And we will find one of these
three to evict to put C there.
In this type of a situation it looks
like B might actually be evicted.
But remember that we also have
value bits for all these blocks.
So when we have a placement policy,
typically we will first fill
all the lines in the cache set before we
move on and start evicting something.
So we will put C into one
of the empty slots, and
now that is the most
recently accessed line.
A is now a hit, and that is now
the most recently accessed line.
Now when we access D, it's not in
the cache, so we will have a miss.
We will again put D in
an unused place and
that will now be the most
recently used one.
Then A gets accessed and
we have a hit, and
at this point A's the most
recently used block.
Now, we will have a miss on E
because it's not in the cache.
And now the question is,
what will be evicted?
We'll definitely not evict A, so
we know that the next four
accesses to A will be all hits.
E will be replacing one
of these three blocks.
So if we replace C or D,
then here we will have a hit.
If we, however, select B for
replacement, and
put E there,
then B here will have a miss.
So we have a hit or a miss here.
In total, we have one, two,
three, four, five, or six misses.
So this is the final
answer to this quiz.